[Musica]
ciao questo sono io da piccola in
germania una bambina mora circondata da
tante bambine bionde
beh eppure sono andato avanti senza
paura
sono cresciuta e poi ho vissuto a roma a
milano a bari a praga e sono arrivata
negli stati uniti
non ho mai smesso di credere ai sogni e
soprattutto non ho mai smesso di credere
al sogno americano walt disney diceva se
puoi sognarlo puoi farlo ed è così che
quest'anno ho partecipato al programma
ivi alpi con il dipartimento di stato
americano un programma nato nel 1940 per
promuovere la conoscenza dell'america un
programma al quale vengono invitati i
leader attuali e vivere emergenti e devo
molto all'america perché mi ha insegnato
a vedere le cose da un'altra prospettiva
e così se in america sono slim
sono giovane e sono considerata una
leader emergente in italia non sono poi
così tanto slim così tanto giovane e non
sono abbastanza uomo per avere potere e
allora oggi sono qui per parlarvi di
block chain
ma proviamo a metterci nella prospettiva
della nostra vicina di casa come
descrivereste block chain alla vostra
vicina di casa
ecco io la descriverei un po così
bruxelles o un po come me e donna e
internazionale anzi possiamo dire
globale e creativa e creativa perché
crea qualcosa di nuovo crea delle nuove
regole cambia i ruoli crea dei leader e
creando
e dei follower può creare delle cose
inaspettate blog chain insomma qualcosa
di più e nel mercato più e sempre di più
come quando henry ford regalo aggiunse
diciamo all'agenda della settimana il
weekend free per i propri operai e le
loro quindi iniziavano a comprare nel
più auto per passare il weekend fuori
porta block chain e sicura perché
validata da una rete di milioni di
attori block chain e democratica è
orizzontale e decentralizzata e quindi
questo la rende più trasparente
responsabilizza le persone e in qualche
modo anche la rende più inclusiva
insomma block chain non è strana e
soltanto wilde è sempre negli stati
uniti grazie al programma ivi alti qui
vedete nella foto i miei colleghi siamo
con greg bennet il vicepresidente di e
jansson vangelo un full ventur
capitalist che è molto interessato alle
start up nel settore block chain e ho
conosciuto anche gillian messing gillian
messing el'acqua fonder di ott la
juventus group un'altra venture
capitalist specializzata nel finanziare
le donne che confrontandoci su questo
tema mi ha detto per me block chain è
veramente interessante e anzi è proprio
la trasparenza di blocco scene che la
rende eccitante e mi ha raccontato il
caso di due start up e in particolare
con krait attraverso la quale gli
investitori possono comprare come se
fossero delle azioni delle quote di
immobili e che trasforma un bene
tangibile quale la proprietà di un
immobile
un bene il liquido in capitale liquido
questo per gillian è fantastico e poi mi
ha parlato di le leggerà un'altra start
up che usa i contratti di affitto
intelligenti agganciati a dei contratti
di servizio in pratica quando affitto un
appartamento in un'unica operazione sono
contenuti più servizi dog sitter
piuttosto che sconti e offerte per i
ristoranti per i bar
insomma in america qualcosa si sta
muovendo ma vi siete mai chiesti quale
sarà il futuro nel mondo di block chain
se in america in qualche modo block
chain bitcoin sono più maturi vengono
considerati strumenti di investimento ma
anche strumenti di valori di scambio in
italia ancora c'è una percezione
soprattutto per bitcoin ma anche
bruxelles di qualcosa di rischioso di
estremamente volatile ma abbiamo
abbastanza informazioni sufficienti
informazioni per esprimere questo
giudizio
nell'era dell'informatica me la
definiscono gli esperti
siamo circondati da informazioni vere
volutamente farsele fec news
erroneamente false le miss informations
siamo in grado di fare discernimento
ecco siamo come diceva de kerkove
nell'accademia di democrazia che abbiamo
fatto a napoli con media duemila
siamo a piedi nudi sulla strada questo
che cosa vuol dire che abbiamo bisogno
di più garanzie per me però block chain
vedendola da un'altra prospettiva è
sicura non è rischiosa è un'informazione
validante block chain e considerata
l'internet delle transazioni è abilitata
alla incorruttibilità e alla
certificazione dei dati e proprio perché
e decentralizzata ha un enorme
potenziale
e allora se in italia per noi è
considerata rischiosa
proviamo
a vedere le cose da un'altra prospettiva
ancora una volta come ci hanno insegnato
gli americani mettiamoci sull'ultimo
piano dello space needle un palazzo
fantastico che ho visitato durante dei
miei p a seattle
qui le cose stanno cambiando in america
per esempio le aziende investono in
block chain si danno una possibilità
e allora proviamo a darci una
possibilità anche noi qui a vedere il
modo diverso la parola impossibile
walter rolfo che è stato speaker di
great place to work
qualche settimana fa ha spiegato proprio
nella parola impossible è contenuta
invece se la guardate bene
l'espressione hien possible
e allora diamoci una possibilità diamo
anche a bruxelles una possibilità del
resto le cose possono andare bene o
possono andare male ma rischiamo noi
abbiamo la libertà di rischiare e anche
il diritto di fallire il diritto di
sbagliare e se gli americani sono
propensi a rischiare addirittura in
america rischiare e fallire sono
considerabili insieme a quella che
abbiamo citato la libertà di stampa che
si festeggia oggi alle cinque libertà
fondamentali nel primo emendamento
potremmo aggiungere quindi oltre
religione libertà di parola di stampa di
assemblea di petizione la libertà di
fallire e di rischiare
eppure non è così in italia fallire è
una colpa
in italia è un diritto che ci è stato
negato i poveri non se lo possono
permettere
i disoccupati non se lo possono
i giovani non se lo possono permettere
insomma a rischiare è un lusso in
america invece rischiare è possibile e
fare
lire è un diritto anzi i venture
capitalist e la considerano una
referenza
insomma in italia dovremmo abituarci di
più a rischio senza paura di fallire
dovremmo provarci è tempo di rischiare
io sono abituata al rischio del resto il
rischio altro non è il successo altro
non è che passare da un fallimento
all'altro senza perdere l'entusiasmo a
me il rischio non fa paura
io sono nata in una città bellissima in
una terra bellissima al più alto rischio
sismico sono abituata a rischiare e
allora block chain why not bitcoin why
not
anzi parliamone di più pensiamo
all'opportunità di educare su questi
temi ci sono settori già avanzati come
in america per esempio dove le compagnie
assicurative multinazionali usano brooks
chain per tracciare e conservare i
contratti e i documenti delle polizze
oppure in uk dove le banche iniziano a
utilizzare bruxelles per ridurre i costi
di transazione ma anche nella logistica
nel mediterraneo ci sono progetti
sperimentali in cui si sta introducendo
bruxelles per digitalizzare documenti e
processi pensiamo poi in giappone dove
si sta sperimentando una nuova
piattaforma di trading energetico e con
le smart grid
si si pensa all accumulo di energia
virtuale in cloud utilizzando e
sfruttando il potere delle transazioni
bruxelles
quest'inverno sono stata per il progetto
integrati sulla trasparenza nei fondi
pubblici a bruxelles e si parla di bluff
scena anche per il public procurement
cioè la commissione europea sta
valutando di utilizzare block chain
proprio per tracciare come vengono
utilizzati i fondi europei e
controllarli e migliorarne la
trasparenza e qui in puglia per esempio
si inizia a usare bruxelles nella
filiera agroalimentare del latte ma
potremo utilizzarla anche in mano
una sperimentale come si sta facendo nel
nord europa per i dati legati i dati
sensibili legati alla salute quindi nel
settore della salute e poi ci sono dei
settori futuribili ancora si parla per
esempio di alcune sperimentazioni nel
voto nel voto elettronico
si parla di alcuni casi di bruxelles
applicata per il crowdfunding ma
pensiamo ancora più a lungo termine
sempre dallo space needle potremmo
utilizzarla per finanziare gli han ben
cat
chi sono gli amber sono 1,7 miliardi di
persone sono giovani sono persone che
vivono in cina india indonesia
bangladesh pakistan brasile africa e non
hanno un conto corrente e che potrebbero
fare impresa anche microattività
iniziando a utilizzare block chain e
allora è tempo di essere wilde è tempo
di pensare anche alle minoranze come
fanno in america come nuovo target per
lo sviluppo le nostre aziende dovrebbero
cambiare strategia giocare al rialzo
perché stiamo rischiando grosso questo è
un articolo che ho letto appena tornata
dall'america
noi stiamo svendendo on line le nostre
isole l'isola di capo passero l'isola di
santa maria di fronte le vendiamo online
nessuno ha provato a gestirle
riprendiamoci salviamo i nostri gioielli
ambientali i nostri gioielli culturali i
nostri territori e proviamo a gestirli
magari anche utilizzando block chain
dobbiamo correre questo rischio dobbiamo
giocare al rialzo l'italia deve
rischiare di più
corriamo il rischio di cadere di nuovo
in una stagnazione nei prossimi anni
mentre lo scenario sul mercato mondiale
continua ad aumentare la propria
concorrenza
cosa succederà se non cambia
strategia quali saranno i costi del non
fare ora questo vuol dire lavorare
profondamente sul turismo creare servizi
per i turisti creare degli attrattori
creare migliori servizi di trasporto più
collegamenti internazionali più
infrastrutture ma anche dare accesso al
credito a piccole e medie imprese
ovviamente curare e proteggere e
preservare il nostro patrimonio
il nostro territorio anche
dall'inquinamento insomma è tempo di
essere guai del tempo di essere pionieri
e noi in italia ne abbiamo tanti
pionieri penso a paola di rosa una
giurista con un innovation mai set di
palermo che è stata una delle prime a
parlare in italia di bruxelles è
invitato a parlarne la start up to tell
you ha cercato di educare le piccole e
medie imprese all'importanza di block
chain per garantire appunto più
sicurezza e tracciabilità dei dati delle
informazioni questo sarebbe successo a
quell'impresa siciliana del tonno
accusata ingiustamente di vendere del
tonno non vero se avesse ascoltato i
consigli di paola e avesse introdotto
blog chain per tracciare la filiera
ma penso anche a francisco spadafora a
capo dell'unità block chain di ntt data
un colosso giapponese che sta a cosenza
e investe sui giovani investe in ricerca
e ha creato un team globale di cui
francisco e membro proprio sul block
chain e penso ancora a giuseppe grisorio
giuseppe sogna di realizzare da tempo un
banco un atm bidirezionale in cui tutti
dentro l'ateneo di bari possono comprare
e vendere in tempo reale cristo valute e
infine penso altro essere pirlo il
prorettore dell'università di bari che
con il dipartimento collabora da tempo
con cyber security il comune di napoli
il comune di bari
i primi progetti sperimentali di big
data
utilizzando block chain insomma sono
questi i nostri eroi urbani da sostenere
e tempo di credere l'oro è tempo di
avere coraggio
non abbiate paura siate wilde
[Applauso]
[Musica]